welcome to this video 15 minute game
playing Beppo boppo from Germany yeah i
can actually transpose to to the
sicilian ok let's do that yeah so often
funny because people don't really know
what sicilian and they still play mc5
but it does not look like that at the
moment aha it's playing the Bishop d7
line this is an interesting variation
that I have employed myself once in a
while in blitz the so-called cupric
variation a very flexible way to play
black here he still has the option to
play like this for example ok I'm
playing the classical variation against
the dragon anyway if I play for at all
so I don't mind this transposition much
yeah why it's a main idea here's some
but there are many many ideas but the
main idea that I like to play as young
do I want to prevent b5 not sure yeah is
to put something on d5 night to d5
forcing a capture and then play it on
the e-file against the e7 pawn so Bishop
f1 and 95 those am this this might be a
the next step in this game is taking
some time Bishop everyone young so that
afore is protected you can play eight h6
yeah exactly I was just thinking not
clear yeah maybe just here g5 is not a
move that lucky necessarily wants to
play it is a weakening of the King side
after all
Gladys looks am quite quite decent 95
will come yeah not sure well this
already Bishop d7 it it slightly limits
blacks options and the normal dragon
variation black very often is able to
play Bishop c8 to e6 in one move which
is not which not happened here I came so
he decides to to to go for that that
that is curious really Bishop g4 hmm
okay I don't necessarily want to play f3
here it's a somewhat weakening but other
than that this looks like but like a
shot in the dark going go anywhere but
if I play Queen to d2 of course there is
maybe night h5 this this this can be a
point that he wants to grab the the
bishop p.m. okay maybe I'll play a 3
after all I really don't want to give up
the bishop this is not strategically
desirable I came 95 now then I guess
Bishop cakes ed night before see father
should be good for white any possible
check here is not really dangerous i
have bishop f2 I mean okay at the moment
it couldn't be six I just take but let's
say he wants to get in an intermediate
move like takes takes between b6
checkers useless because of Bishop f2
white Bishop f2 can be an idea anyway to
solve a foursome to take on d5 so gap
here by the way I think I'm
strategically speaking of threatening to
play see form switching back to a maraca
see point in which h6 and g5 looks
fairly
very weird okay so he does not really
think this is a threat yeah okay a
threat is is a strong word but ok it's
attacking me too I I get the idea mm-hmm
okay he's so attacking the B to pawn
yeah that's interesting that's really
interesting maybe a way to to play so C
3 first I don't need to place afore it
only would have been interesting rook be
one looks looks a bit sick young then
let's just let's just do that that's
okay yeah I always think that a position
where you put in the knight on d5 must
be quite quite okay for white at least
them there should be some some sort of
advantage it's simply the case with the
many dragon type structures that night
25 is a very annoying procedure that
black needs to needs to do to combat
quite often this is not applying to too
many lines for e-cigs has played like
the night off Chevening in a night
offers the wrong example but the
shitlist the ravening and variation
trying to print out this correctly this
happening and variation there the e6
phone is always making sure that knight
on d5 is not not going to be too much of
a problem okay interesting here I can
play 90 form this could be a way
intending to take on e6 yeah I'll do
that the night on b3 is so it's not
really so useful anyway so 94 is
probably all right if he takes it he
takes d I'm ready to play night f5 so I
think Bishop g5 is really really not
good
the question is is night xe6 a threat
it's bone structure is weakened of
course but the f porn switching to e6 is
controlling those important squares d 4
85 + f5 yeah mmhmm yeah I don't really
know maybe a 96 isn't a threat but there
is night f5 p.m. if he does not react at
all 22 22 this let's say it plays the
move like the rook c8 for example yeah
some scorn of some sort of
normal-looking move then night f5 is
very annoying very annoying with
threatening not only seven and taking
the the bishop this is why g5 was really
always a very very young double edged
decision it wins the tempo it helps to
come to 5 45 but it's very much
weakening the King side which is not
easily fixed or repaired in a way ponsor
don't move backwards very famous quote
but it's very very true
yeah I'm not quite sure I mean I really
like why its position here because i'm
always a fan of centralization and and
porn control in the center like this
pawn only for him but i'm not so sure
how difficult to the position really is
neither hive is really a problem and if
he takes on d4 d5 this is not solved the
night at five is the next move hmm at
the moment i am not so sure what black
here should do interesting okay well
night takes is six as I already said I
don't think is terribly great but what
about night at five isn't this just very
strong yeah that that's just good for
what I think taking you takes f is just
very nice for white or D 5 I take um
this the seventh is hanging so this is
basically necessary and now this is just
a great PCM the question is how to
continue should I maybe I can play this
really very directly with with F form he
maybe we'll play e6e six
yeah which is not not fantastic for
black as well but it's my turn still be
the relatively best defense
yeah I like f1 playing playing directly
here opening up the kingside does this
should be good he cannot really retreat
the night and now I have a very very
tempting choice i can take with the
bishop or with the night and both them
both move look good I take with the
night there is night h5 on the on the
cards a tick with the bishop there there
might be six and it's also very nice
yeah that's also nice 693 then queen age
5 or maybe if he goes Knight f6 I have
other ways to get pieces to the attack I
only shouldn't take addresses this is
not good but I can just go back this
this should be okay I am their queen h5
looks looks like a real problem so I
guess he needs to do d5 p.m. then I g4
is also a very very interesting move
just we didn't do that interesting
Queen age five now Knight f6 queen edge
for ya it should be ok i don't want to
spend a jcm about two minutes ahead on
the clock which does not happen so often
and i like to keep the the time
advantage I have easy easy moves to
strengthen go here and now maybe also
just look the one getting all the pieces
involved yeah yeah that's that sets of
course interesting
yeah it's a good end game that's just a
good end game I wanted to play for
medium but ok and then if it's a if it's
supposed to be a good end game I'll take
that no problem at all okay rook do you
one yeah rock t 1 1st taking d6
loop the eight probably d5 there is this
tactic night XD five which should to win
a pond so rook the ADA's probably going
to be played and after that i can i can
just take only 61 one possible move and
i can sorry consider consider other
other options because well i don't
really think he threatens to check on f5
this looks like Swiss cheese pawn
structure okay okay I'll do that keep it
simple it's just a good structure no use
and doing anything anything too fancy
there's also night c4 here which maybe
is just a kind of simple and good move I
can also take on e5 this this will
actually win a poor Nia it read win the
pawn or he will or or or you must take
with with the pawn takes Bishop takes
Knight g4 we will win upon age six Hanks
if I thanks ecigs eggs it's too much one
night c4 I have both them both is
looking good okay I'm doing that I mean
Bishop b5 de five is also very
advantageous but I don't really want to
put opposite colored bishops on the
board not when I when I don't need you
I wonder I wonder night night I didn't
do that not see forever if I would have
been able to play rookie six probably
not a turn still wasn't totally crazy
yeah d 6 is just hanging I mean he needs
to address that and taking Bishop takes
I mean what what about is six that's not
going to end without any material loss
very likely ok bishop ok rookie six I
don't think snide f8 coming ok Bishop d3
is one good move
I go 23 okay he probably needed to do
that king of seven rook f1 looked look
at them very very tricky so should I
pile up on the e porn or what is the the
right the right setup c4 also is in
general an idea but I don't see BB to
are saying so okay I'm playing this this
seems like a flexible flexible set up
only question is what is my my exact
plan the real plan here maybe I trading
rooks would be would be quite quite good
actually then opening up for the two
bishops here I could try to place you
for I mean be two now is protected okay
let's let's do that
it does not in any way improve his pawn
structure yes it would be an isolated
pawn on d5 or it takes and e6 is even
attacked by the bishop so we will have a
change in pawn structure but not an
improvement for black guy thinks he for
was was was a good idea a only real way
to make any direct progress the main
difference in the position between white
and black is okay pawn structure to pawn
eyelids against three but the night on
evade at the moment is totally dominated
by the d3 bishop which is excellent
interesting so if i take he will take
with the rock i guess yeah okay i will
take and now hmm
yeah well the pawn here is now in in
some way hanging I wonder how to play
that should I go be three I don't want
Bishop g4 teenage one this is not so
attractive
hmm
yeah should I should I exchange here
early i don't i don't know really this
check is ass really a bit a bit
irritating okay Bishop before I play
Bishop f2 and exchange this the the
bishop on d three SS is better anyway
than the night so I think I don't want
to click King edge 1 this does not look
right so on this check i just play
Bishop f2
yeah thats it's all nice for white but
it's not not totally easy more anything
at least for my level of technical play
from from a practical point of view it's
good news that he spends lots of time
well I i generally understand that plug
is not able to dash I would move after
move after move as it's not so easy to
play this position it's not not very
comfortable many little problems are
there I mean let's say you play harmless
looking like 96 thurs Bishop f5 with a
very awkward pin just an example of a
normal-looking move that it's not good
maybe you really should give this check
okay this this way yeah but I have rook
f2 okay that's bless Bishop g4 that's a
neat little trick so should f5 may be
okay while the catcher is simple and it
good so don't let's let's not be too
sophisticated about it should f5 and
this is not really too much so maybe
here
yeah the night does not have a great
square I mean it can go to e6 but I have
Roo gave six after that attacking age
six and this is not easy to come on 95
there's also Bishop Bishop f5 I think
pressure that five should be good rook
f7 though no okay it's not a problem
look f7 I can just take and play before
and the night needs to go on a light
square where there will be some some
discovery ok and now he's got the
problem what to do ok now i can play
before now now the night has no square i
think no good one it's either taken with
check or on a for Bishop c 2 i'll take
it next move on I just forgot about that
very nice very nice my explanation but
it's completely bogus great I simply
forgot that you can return ok while
white still looks a bit better but this
wasn't really the plan not to not really
hmm what's what the heck
hmm Jeff Jim that that's really bad I
thought maybe maybe I can can go to them
to the pure and my nap is end game which
should be quite good for me okay what
he's got an active King yeah not sure
but ok I've got three minutes and this
was very stupid yeah I just I just
didn't think of 96 I just didn't I
really thought I'm winning instantly
which obviously did not did not happen
we came and if i take now this night to
have form brilliant
okay not sure if this even as still as
something probably it's about equal if
at all I mean black has has some active
pieces now as I really thoroughly miss
plate okay well still still d5 is
hanging in there is Luke age five
possibly should I try that okay if I get
age 6 this is this is nice so maybe it's
still it's still good the ship to g3 g4
I triad okay in this form it still looks
like wider should be it should be
comfortable but I was really I didn't do
it didn't play this very convincingly
check you know he don't he does not
really have much can try try this
getting getting the night to have four
but it's not not helping a great deal
that FY give the check and play rupee
form attacking the porn here check
no what about rook f5 is this good not
sure but the pond is rather dangerous
yeah I think it should be it should be
okay I mean this is the thing I mean I
could I can now if I want I could just
stop to play chess and win this on time
this is why I'm so hugely in favor of
increment no I can I can basically play
any movement and windows on time but
it's still an interesting position that
needs to be played um okay we can try
getting that word am i will just advance
with the King yeah I Scott King e5
yeah I have this this dangerous pesum
and I still have the queenside that I
can attack so I think it still should be
very good good for what yeah you cannot
move the night from them now I can try
to get get to the pawn here let's let's
see if I manage that Bishop d1 yeah this
will be a time when we should push up
two or three but I think white is just
just just when a long time yeah it's a
he really spent a bit a bit too much
time other than that so it was a good
defense yeah here here why this is
already a better again I what I did is I
totally totally screwed up this this
thing I bishop be sick since winning
yeah I didn't look for anything like
that this is just winning material
because I was just totally brain-dead
thinking that that he has to move here
but he can't explain 86 I was just
thinking it is winning this is my was my
problem i played this rather instantly
there should be six is of course winning
immediately y and here he probably with
precise player shouldn't lose here here
in fact i don't really know if I still
have anything I mean he's very active
king is in the mill maybe he can push
some even himself with g4
now this is a probably quite ok and then
with little time on the clock he
gradually am allowed that you got got
pushed back and this is already nuts not
very comfortable get here I think I
think this should win this is too much
the f porn and I still have the
queenside that I can attack yeah
probably a win here yeah I allowed a bit
too much this is a very good end game
and I think it was it was fine up until
I had this hallucination with the with
the route capture yeah okay still
interesting game here in 15 minutes time
control I hope you liked it thanks for
watching